I'm happy to show you the evidence of
the build at £500,000 if you agreed to
them posting a full apology video and
I'm just a good negotiator he then
deleted my comments so now I'm like all
right what the heck's going on here so I
messaged rudo and I said to rudo
Friendly warning take it down or I will
have no choice but to instruct my
solicitors to take immediate action
tomorrow he then blocks me right I'm
thinking is this dude really a
professional so my lawyers messaged him
the following morning and sent him a
full breakdown of the development to
prove that actually everything I said
was true and his video is complete
nonsense and to be fair to him he has
now sent me the figures of the build and
I can confirm that and then the video
cut so he doesn't want to apologize he
doesn't want to take down the videos
even though he knows that everything he
said about my figures not stacking up
was wrong because he's seen the receipt